but um I want to talk a little bit about
rlhf uh we spoke about that before we
started recording and that has a very
interesting effect on on language models
so it's not so much it changes their
capabilities but it creates an interface
for us to use but in in the most
abstract
um sense how do you understand rlh
yeah so I I think um
so in in popular culture now there's
actually quite a good meme that explains
it
um I think it kind of carries the spirit
of it which is this uh Shogun meme that
you've probably seen yeah uh where uh
the idea is that like the base model
that's just trained to model P of X the
distribution over internet text uh
that's this very sort of chaotic being
that you know has all you don't it's
it's uh it's this very like enormous
being that essentially has modeled the
whole internet of text and so there's
lots of um crevices within that
distribution and there's both good and
bad there's uh
there's a lot of probably hate speech
but then also lots of very brilliant
content as well
um and so that's kind of what you get if
you just model the whole internet as a
distribution and using next token
prediction on these large models
um and then of course the problem
becomes if I ask this model to
essentially perform a task by
essentially providing it a prompt like a
prefix into a text that I wanted to
complete then it's it can be difficult
to anticipate how it's going to complete
it like if I ask it um a question
uh about calculus is it going to
complete it as a professor of math or is
it going to complete it by giving me a
response from a random you know like
commenter on 4chan or like a Reddit post
and you might get wildly different
qualities of responses based on that
um in reality
um it's sort of this like
giant mass of just people that it's
modeled and so it's like multiple
personalities times a billion people on
the internet that's what it's modeling
and so then this meme basically says
okay well rlhf is basically sticking
essentially like a smiley face on top of
this where it's essentially giving you
um it's basically hiding this mess it's
hiding the fact that it's you know this
chaotic like population of text that
it's modeled and instead uh it's going
to provide you with a a very friendly
interface into specific parts of that uh
mass of people it's modeling and the way
it's doing that is it's basically
training
it's fine-tuning the model on a reward
signal that's um that itself is learned
from uh human preference data so
basically they collect human feedback
data from different generations of the
language model and they essentially use
that to train another model that outputs
a feedback signal for whether given an
input how good is an output so it's
modeling human preferences
that's um empirically collected
um and then you use that as a reward
signal to fine-tune the predictions the
generations of your language model so
treating the language model now in the
fine-tuning phase as a reinforcement
learning policy so like basically given
what I've generated thus far like uh and
the prompt what should I what is the
next token I should predict and so
treating this as a reinforcement
learning problem
uh where the reward signal is this human
preference model and so um what that's
doing is it's essentially saying you
started with P of X which is modeling
the distribution of internet text and
now we're going to use RL where we're
basically going to start to introduce
bias into this distribution
um so what what is interesting about
this is that when you train a typical
language model you're basically training
it with something like a cross entropy
loss and cross entropy loss is
equivalent to a Divergence metric
between two distributions and so when
you do this
um you're essentially you know if you
had tons of uh computation and when the
process converges you should expect that
your model is essentially learning to
model it's minimizing the distributional
Divergence this distance between
distributions uh between its learn
distribution over text and the training
data distribution over text and so
basically when this process converges
when you minimize this loss it should
actually be matching the distribution of
text on the internet
what reinforcement learning does is
almost the opposite of this
reinforcement learning is not doing
distribution matching reinforcement
learning is mode seeking so if you had
some data where you say
um I have maybe 51 of a positive I have
51 percent of an example where the right
answer is a and uh 49 where the right
answer is B but I can't tell ahead of
time like which which answer it should
be because maybe the two inputs are
aliased then reinforcement learning is
going to if you keep training the policy
to maximize the reward it's going to
always choose the first answer because
it's got a slight bias in the
distribution but by always choosing it
you're going to maximize the reward in
expectation that's what it's doing so
reinforcement learning is mode seeking
and so when you apply this on top of um
a p of X that you've learned to just
like that's distribution matching
internet text you're essentially
introducing these like mode seeking
biases into your model and so it's going
to tend to the the generations are going
to tend to hone in more they're going to
tend to call perhaps more towards the
types of outputs the part of the the the
domain of language where human
preferences have assigned learned human
preference has assigned a higher reward
and so what you're doing is you're
losing a lot of the diversity of P of X
so you're losing a lot of diversity in
exchange for perhaps more reliable
Generations that take you more into the
parts of the distribution
um the original distribution that had
more you know higher quality answers so
maybe now if it's tuned to give me good
answers on math questions now if I ask
it a calculus question it'll tend to
favor those those uh completions that
are modeling the outputs of a college
professor of math rather than you know
someone who's like asking the same
question on Reddit and saying help I
don't know how to do this problem yes
yes so what could possibly go wrong
um yeah as you say so a language model
it's learning this conditional
probability distribution conditioned on
a sequence of tokens what's the next
token can and that probability
distribution has loads of modes it's
like this big hilly landscape and some
of the modes are you know
um 4chan some of the modes are Stanford
University and we want to kind of like
snip out all of the bad ones and all of
the ones that we like we we want to
remain now I guess I wanted your
intuition on how this pruning can we
call it a pruning process how that
affects both the capability and the bias
yeah so I think it essentially improves
um how reliable the answers are by
introducing a bias so you're biasing the
model to generate
um completions that were favored by
humans in the preference uh in the when
you collected the preference data and so
if you assume the preference model that
it's used to train on is a is a proper
reflection of the human preferences then
it is biasing the model towards those
that whatever human participants used
preferred and so that itself also
introduces bias because it's like the
specific humans that are providing their
value
um assignments to the completed answers
they're you're essentially distilling
their reward like you're distilling
their preferences and so the actual
humans the choice of humans for
collecting the preferences is very
important
um because you're ultimately the model
is going to exhibit those values as well
and uh this is at the cost of the
diversity of the generations that you
can you can sample because uh rather
than sampling lots of different possible
paths where again like from the why
greatness cannot be planned perspective
right that's quite that's quite like
useful sometimes because maybe by
generating something that's unlikely
under a fine-tuned model it's actually
acting as like a prefix stepping stone
to like a better answer right that just
that somehow was um glanced over within
the preference function that you learned
um you end up generating uh of less
diversity and so you end up going
towards maybe answers that are good but
maybe there's better answers or there's
more interesting answers
um that would otherwise be generated
could have touched on a couple of things
I mean even before we do rl8 Chef when
you look at the um the probability
distribution it's kind of it's It's
exponentially distributed so it's still
likely to say the next word is this and
this and much less likely to be
something else but as you say from a
open-ended perspective we are making it
far more convergent and you could argue
yeah it's a form of robustification but
then when the humans give their
preferences you know we were talking
about good earlier that's a proxy so we
have benchmarks like big bench we have
um this human over there said it looked
like a good output yep and what what's
the right thing to do I guess what I'm
saying is that there's there's what's
right from an alignment point of view so
there's morality and ethics there's
being able to perform well on
mathematics challenges and there's this
human over there thought it was a good
thing to do
yeah I mean I think it really depends on
the use case uh so this is kind of tying
back to the industry slant because I
think that our lhf in some it does make
a lot of sense if you want your language
model to essentially be a Google
replacement if you want it to be a
search engine then it makes a lot of
sense to bias it towards
um a subset of the distribution that
corresponds to like good answers to
search queries
um but this is going to like an example
of when this would be in more perhaps
direct opposition to a use case to
another use case would be if you want to
use a language model
um as a creative writing assistant right
if I want to use the language model to
help me generate new creative art in the
form of a novel or a short story or a
poetry
um by using HF you're reducing the
diversity of the outputs because you're
basically saying I'm going to play it
safe rather than uh play the wild card
and get more interesting content but
when you're an author when you want to
actually create new cultural content
that's interesting you often want to
play the Wild Card you want to explore
the space of ideas you wanna and
sometimes items that requires going
through Stepping Stones of ideas that
maybe are pretty sub-optimal or maybe
controversial or offensive
um but that's all required to get to
somewhere better which is maybe
somewhere where you can't get if you
were just following the uh RL rohf uh
fine-tuned trajectories yes and and
that's why lots of um creative people I
think I read on less wrong they prefer
using the original DaVinci 3 because
they thought that the command models
were less created but um here's
something interesting I mean as an
open-ended person